our friends at travel texas want you to
go big or go home in texas and the ccma
awards presented by td are going big in
calgary this year co-hosts teneal towns
and blanco brown are following in the
cowboy boots of some impressive previous
hosts like lindsay l billy ray cyrus and
shania twain and the parents sat down
with us to talk about what they are
bringing to this year's show airing
sunday september 11th on global
so what do you think makes you to the
perfect combo for canada's biggest night
in country music i think the people
chose
and we just gonna take the ride and
enjoy the moment be professional funners
yeah i think there is a lot of joy
between both of us there's like
definitely a spirit of joy that's gonna
be i think bubbling through this show so
honored to do it beside him what can
audiences expect directly from the two
of you up on that stage can you give us
any details i know you're working
everything through right now there's an
opening number that's going to be pretty
fun but we're both performing new songs
which is very exciting so you'll
definitely see both of those
performances have you been practicing
the get up choreography now take your
left hand and put it on your side
gonna roll your shoulders
do the slip inside i got i'm gonna need
a lesson from blanco to really cross me
over the finish line here but i'm i'm i
think i'm ready
my dance moves are not they're not
awesome but i will be smiling the whole
time so that's all that matters
lie to
[Music]
will we see like a brittany and justin
canadian tuxedo moment like would we
will there be will there be jean wear is
what i want to know or not
you're definitely going to see some
jeans on me
[Music]
i've got some jeans packed too we've got
the denim covered
presented by travel texas from the
pristine gulf coast to incredible arts
culture and outdoor adventure texas has
something for everyone texas go big or
go home
[Music]